Hey Youtubers It's Charlie new Star Wars footage
we see a lot more Princess Leia her daughter
is even in this clip so let's break down if
you're watching this in the United States
and you may have seen this during Shonda land
which is like the ABC block of programming
is is about like female driven shows this
is weird stuff during scandal and they posted
this but when whatever new footage of new
footage biggest things first thin downward
striking with a light saber attacking a storm
trooper which looks like it has a charged
weapon that's blocking the light saber because
the storm trooper that he's fighting it looks
just like a normal storm trooper I'm wondering
if in the time since return of the Jedi the
people that know the Jedi light saber technology
have try to adapt to it they did reveal a
bunch of stuff about Luke JJ Abrams was talking
about how how he fits into this movie thematically
he says that Luke is more of a myth that people
like Ray the younger characters don't know
a lot about them but the first-order actually
indoctrinate their soldiers during childhood
and teaches them about the evil Luke Skywalker
who destroyed the wonderful empire CW the
idea if you ever saw that Seth Rogen film
the interview the good interview Kim Jong-Il
to North Korea and all the people are led
to believe these really hilarious lies about
them it's kind of the same thing the first
order is doing to their new storm troopers
so Finn who does start out as a storm trooper
has been taught about the evil Luke Skywalker
growing up but raise character who's been
living in isolation, like the way Luke Skywalker
grew up on tattooing doesn't know anything
about Luke Skywalker chichi is actually no
idea who he is JJ Abrams actually even even
made some jokes about the classic storm troopers
versus the new storm troopers is like you
the classic trilogy there are kinda there
to stand around get shot not being able to
shoot any of the heroes actually the worst
shots with a blaster they can at the side
of the star destroyer they tried that she
tried to inject a lot of pathos and character
into these individual storm troopers that
we meet during the force awakens so you learn
about why everyone hates Luke Skywalker so
much in speaking of thin he is supposed to
have a certain amount of history with Poe
Dameron here my guess is is that he helps
Poe Dameron escape Poe gets captured by Kylo
Ren interrogated from what you see in this
scene that at some point he has to escape
Finn is probably part of that but the big
thing is we see Leah here in her control room
she's being called general in these new films
obviously she's stopping a princess the minute
Alderaan was blown up the people been talking
about like it's a big thing really is not
the Big Bang most of the younger people in
the film grew up in the galaxy without all
the rancid so they would have never thought
of hers Princess they did say that there is
like this funny moment in the film when someone
calls or Princess and it causes like this
big stir like she gets really upset you can
imagine if no one knows her as Princess who
would be calling her princess obviously can
be Han Solo but we almost see the full original
Trinity here is a generally I guess we should
call her now see Han Solo three PO with his
red arm mysterious red arm and then in the
background here you see Billy Lord that's
actually Carrie Fisher's real-life daughter
whenever it was announced that she was to
be in the film everybody wondered if she's
gonna be a young Princess Leia that's not
the case you just playing a background character
in these resistant scenes but there was also
some confusion about this Ray Han Solo Siemers
like your money this is handing her the blaster
that she buyers to Kylo Ren here I disease
in new sites reporting this is a light saber
and it is not a lifesaver she's can have that
staffer most of the film until she gets this
blaster here's my question for you guys though
do you feel like the 30 years it's been since
return of the Jedi is enough for this first
order like the remanence of the empire which
is being called the first-order to indoctrinate
a bunch of people against Luke Skywalker is
definitely keeping with the spirit is something
of the empire would try to do but oh I almost
forgot we actually learn some new stuff about
Maz Kanata from JJ Abrams as well as supreme
leader snoke from Andy Serkis of Maz Kanata
she is 1000 years old which is moving into
your territory is not a member of your species
but she's been a pirate for a long time when
she is saying I've seen your eyes before it's
a much grander statement that it sounds like
the thing about any circuses character he
said the supreme leader's note is the leader
of the first-order he is a really big character
he's completely CG like he's way way too big
way way bigger than a normal person he has
no connection to anything that happened in
the previous films and he has this really
strange weakness is vulnerable in a really
unusual way which makes it sound like he stays
inside like a Vader chamber like innovator
special chamber I'm not expecting to see a
lot of them and episode seven thematically
I think it's gonna be like the Luke Skywalker
thing worth like you see them a little bit
towards the end of the movie then they become
much bigger thing in episode a primarily excited
especially to see Finn just like hacking away
at ship with his light saber and they did
confirm that does come from Maz Kanata said
that this scene is her handing it off to Leah
that make me wonder if she's the one to handed
to Finn but that's just speculation and other
related cool Star Wars happenings there's
a cool behind-the-scenes special that could
be on the Disney Channel tonight if you get
it definitely check it out its was to be on
at 830 all totally do a video for it if it
is not too long post holding my channel and
forget the giveaway still going on at this
two IMAX tickets for episode seven oriented
enters be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video is all announced the winners
whenever I post my next Star Wars video while
you guys wait for that to post you can click
here for my episode 7 playlist of all the
trailers I've been posting and you can click
here for the latest Jessica Jones trailer
that I just posted think you so much for watching,
everybody high five and I'll see you guys
tonight!